do cyborgs have a mantle  i call you a sophomore  you look like arnold schwarzenegger and  terminator because you're trying to just  kill people like a robot it don't show  no emotion whatsoever i love it yeah  just that'll try to stay locked in into  the game um  you know i feel like when people are the  most serious they they play their best  basketball sometimes um nobody's smiling  in the fourth quarter you know what i  mean if you're trying to make a basket  so do cyborgs have a  whatsoever i love it yeah i'll just try  to stay locked in into the game um you  know i feel like when people are the  most serious they they play their best  basketball sometimes nobody's smiling in  the fourth quarter you know what i mean  if you're trying to make a basket so